meeting held on the 9th of august
reading from bottom page numbers
8 3
4.
yes rose
did steve speak to jeffrey cox about the
front of the houses
chair yeah it's on the action list as
well
but yes uh councillor james councillor
hodgson and i had a meeting with uh
jeffrey parks for the 20th of august uh
so we relayed the concerns of members
and we followed that up this is a range
of information and questions uh
generally planned in terms of uh
challenges specific statistics and we've
provided those to them
okay
move on bottom page four
five
six
you're happy with those minutes
oh
[Music]
that is unanimous thank you
item three the action list on page seven
dealt with minute 150
158
yes
i miss the question sorry that
everybody's looking at me
christy asked if you actually knew the
number of the people that were on the
house invest
we've provided information to past the
christian school by jeffrey cox
currently
the latest district it's around about
820
but that changes from month to month
that's 820
yes yes
and for laws
[Music]
[Music]
look very urgently at the situation of
housing
i know it's always a high priority
we really do need
is that 820 people on the housing
waiting list or is it 820 people on the
waiting list that want to swap houses as
well it's it's false it comes
housewarming yeah so
some people on there are housed already
yes yes um
there's different findings of that need
depending on a person's individual
circumstances and so not all of those
would be considered priority made as in
um impending um homelessness and and
have a full probability as a household
in fact out of all of those people from
the deaf entrance sisters and very few
will be considered priority room but
these are people who are on a waiting
list for um housing association property
either in this district or any other
district in devon as long as they meet
the criteria for moving to another
district so the vast majority of those
are already
in housing
and it's just they're looking to move
and they're on that list that register
and to be considered as part of their
demographics
thanks for watching thank you when i ask
this um originally
i think we're all aware of the problems
which only seems a lot worse i mean
council of the lords is
quite right we will need to look at this
fairly soon
um it's very difficult because because
all developers is all they ever want to
build it seems
three bedroom state houses
um there's a really interesting article
in the days
about a developer in london who's
firstly not going for the 20 profit that
they all say they must have
the second is actually building smaller
unions
because a lot of our
people who want housing
nobody seems to be building i wonder if
we should look at that in our local plan
and start when we start identifying
areas and that's going to be an area
[Music]
our members will be aware that we have
started looking at work on housing and
the report will be brought back to full
council on the first of november to the
next
council meeting after one next week
and that's uh looking at those options
where the council may be able to or may
wish to intervene
before having the permission of the
border function
i can't say this stage what members may
or may not decide to do
council i don't have that information to
handle because that changes on a
week-by-week basis obviously we have our
our hostels and we utilize um other
temporary accommodations such as a
travel agent and that sort of thing so
i'll have to get
[Music]
it really does very quickly must look
seriously out there
it becomes worse you don't have that
many rooms in travel autism
all the years i've been on the council
i've never known as much as i've heard
this evening about the
state of the housing list
it's something that's always kept well
away from members of my experience and
it's rather frightening
because
i'm just suspicious how many are
desperate for housing
you know we're told that we've got to do
20 30 40
on the affordable housing
if we really push on that all that
happens is the developers say they
viable to develop in dollars will go
elsewhere where we can get away with it
so it's not quite so easy as we make out
but i'd really like to know as a spot
the genuine figure number desperately in
need today
those who would benefit those who sort
of just found see something different
i think we you know it would be helpful
to all to know yes steve church is
something that's included in the
council's quarterly business report uh
that's reviewed by internal food
scrutiny and the committee of vast
janet's to come back to that committee
uh with details of that at the next
meeting
uh so that that piece of work is also in
front of the channel to report back to
uh internal scrutiny
council james
they said if we opened it up to
outsiders
we would get loads
just how much of that is being effective
in these figures
but that's all i've got was a choice
but we've recently closed one family
that wasn't
is
foreign
a council of court with deals with the
hungers she actually gave her support on
the town council about this and more
agreed quite frankly because a lot of it
is hidden
uh we've got social services
like that and she's in contact with
those really
quite an eye opener to listen
i have to say like
captain james was offering a place
probably not everyone wants well they
don't like that i can tell you the
bridge trust when we
advertise these individuals
thank you mr chairman um
as far as i'm aware and janet will
correct me on shore seven home choice to
a whole range of reports
of actually categorizing their
applicants into
the levels of housing need
because you will find that you have um
do we still have entourage down to any
or has we discussed
some authorities don't um indeed yeah
because it's faster and more housing
for
billable housing there's a lot of people
with higher needs and that have been
categorised yeah
so i think it's very important that we
as members understand that
people fill in our housing application
to go on that register some of them are
um
using it as a safeguard that they might
need to be accommodated or they might
need to move to more suitable
accommodation
so it's the actual
need factor that i think we've got to
focus on which gives you a completely
different set of figures
so i think you know we as members need
to know what the up-to-date
uh category a there are very few
in that they are the ones who need to be
housed now
and then you've got the bees which are
the ones that need to be
housed
asap and i think those are the ones we
need to really get our heads around to
know what kind of response
we should be working on
so i think those figures are really
critical
to inform us
thank you
thank you
um is there any update then on the
afghan
we have pledged um our support to two
refugee families over two years and we
can't go above that at the moment that's
what's being approved and the the
pledges for the commitment is for either
the syrian or the afghan scheme
and but there is a lot of interest and
obviously pressure from governments to
uh to try and recount um the recent
inputs of the
afghan refugees we're working with
county on that at the moment and we're
hoping to shortly and put out a request
for landlords uh specifically for the
refugee scheme we have had a number of
individuals approach us and
unfortunately that that accommodation
has either be
spare rooms um or time limited
properties but we're looking for
something they're self-contained and
sustainable in the long term so at the
moment uh
simply because they have homeless
problems as it is people
looking to be rehoused or posed in the
first place so they don't want to take
any more any further commitments
and so it's not just this area we have a
problem with opponents lists down the
countries uh
[Music]
yeah
right i think for something not only
gender that's going on longer now
i do look forward to seeing those
figures in duke course
i think we've finished our agenda items
three which is action list
and we move on to number four
public contributions i've no evidence of
any known as anybody else so we can move
on
item five forward plan h8
any comments there on
[Music]
councillor
[Music]
and i've had
one member of the public approach me and
say that porridge hasn't met their
uh timeline
be developing a planet
and they're quite upset haven't we
have you had any
further update on that
yeah so so we have had the update on our
funding bid
um we
have had a valuation report returned to
us
we
attempted to reopen negotiations with
the primary landowner on the site but
his preference was to do some more
investigation work in advance of that
uh the development management team have
been progressing uh the proposals that
will form the planning application we
haven't submitted the planning
application yet
and it's not interesting to be submitted
[Music]
uh
no i mean i think the indication was
that we would would have heard this
month and that's
every lightning
slipped but we don't have right hand on
so i don't know i don't know what to say
that's what uh chair i think all the
indication was four term
it's it's now all right so that could be
the start middle or end of all term
um whether that's likely to sit
alongside the spending review which also
hasn't got a date assigned to it yet um
which they specify the year
they specified the year that we've got
complete schemes
okay
so we move on item
six
you don't need me to
lay down the rules on that
item seven there's nothing proposed for
part two
unless we get into the mile we don't
need to go there
meet them eight
urgent matters i have none
so we move on to item nine
biosphere nature recovery plan and
declaration pages 1915
only
thank you
[Music]
good evening everybody
so um members will be aware of the
projects and partnerships that the north
end biosphere is involved with and as a
local authority we have an enviable
opportunity to work with a
world-renowned organization committed to
improving our local environment and
developing sustainable practices over a
range of industries and businesses in
our area
and as a local authority we've stated
our role and ambitions improving local
biodiversity through our recently
doctoral problem environmental
biodiversity plan so this report seeks
to draw these two elements together and
to highlight to members the biosphere's
nature recovery plan and to seek
approval to pledge our support for their
natural current declaration
so the drivers from the natural
government planner uh simply recognition
of the pressures and threats by
diversity that are apparent at every
level from from global to local there's
an interplay between biodiversity loss
and climate change and the destruction
of wildlife habitats and the
intensification of land groups it all
goes hand in hand
with the impacts on our climate and
pressure to acknowledge to educate and
to take action to address these issues
and that are gradually making above the
agenda
the biosphere developed this nature
recovery plan looking to focus on
restoring existing nature habitats to
good condition and ensuring connectivity
between them rather than encouraging
significant changes in land use
the recovery plan focuses on five key
land types which together cover the
majority of northern devon so those of
course
grassland arable towns and villages
trees woodlands and hedges wetlands and
water bodies
under each of these headings priorities
are identified and against each priority
the lead organisation is identified
together with an estimated cost for
undertaking our facilities in the work
some actions have existing resources or
part of an existing workload or work
plan and the source of any additional
funding to facilitate and undertake
these additional actions have not yet
been identified those aren't in the
plans
so local authorities are identified as a
lead partner or supporting partner for
several actions primarily within the
towns and villages section while some of
these actions within these sections are
already starting to be delivered the
actions are
intended to be challenging but
achievable the actions are aspirational
but not set as binding targets that must
be met by a partner organization rather
they are intended to be aspirational
targets or visions towards all partner
organizations can seek to contribute
towards
so sitting underneath this plan is the
nature recovery declaration which
members are being asked to sign up to
today
the declaration of companies the nature
recovery plan
this is an invitation for any
organizational individual across
northern devon to sign up to the
declaration to pledge to undertake a
number of actions and the list of
actions differs between individuals and
different types of organizations
cumulatively enough
people and organizations undertaking
these actions will contribute
significantly towards delivering the
vision and meeting the actions set out
in the nature recovery plan
in the report there's a list of
potential actions that the local
authority can consider and these are
included in sections 2.9 of the report
and all of these actions are considered
to be appropriate and should be
achievable for tbc
so this report seeks to make members
aware of the biosphere's nature recovery
plan and to seek approval to sign up to
the nature republican declaration that
sits alongside it so that we can show
our commitment to working with the
biosphere on improving
biodiversity across northern devon and
aligning our aspirations with those of
the biosphere
so that's the report before you members
and i'm happy to see more questions
chancellor roles
how does this policy sit with a thousand
houses above westwood
with containing no
nature at all
this council i know is governed by
platinum law but
it's just going to end up
as five great big states
bare minimum of grass
yeah how's that
as you'll be awakened to the laws and
through our current planning policy we
do have quite a progressive policy
on um biodiversity net gain
so there should have been an assessment
of biodiversity loss as part of
planning applications that you refer to
and then that is um
offset elsewhere plus 10 extra and but
this is um
really a planning matter with
the planning workshop last week around
climate change and biodiversity so if
that's something that can be improved on
in the future then the review of the
local plan will
facilitate that
thank you sorry throwing me throwing
that at you i'm not gonna miss an
opportunity fair enough i'd expect
nothing less
[Music]
than mr christine
yes um council laws ask questions about
we had a planning application which came
to us where there was going to be some
offset
and
i was astounded to find the offset was
actually in my walls first i'd heard
and didn't came to the valley where i
was not
and
i wonder if there isn't
some scope here for
the planning department
to really start getting these active and
telling councils what's being planned
for their war because it came with
[Music]
no problem with that but it would be
nice to know what's going on and as soon
as officers do get planned to come in
i would like to know what you've been
planning
for thanks for christy i mean that's a
matter for our planning department
obviously but i think by signing up to
this declaration um you know we're
looking at trying to improve our our
activity and transparency around those
things so you know i'd have no issues
with that
but i think that's really how it's going
to go with a lot of these offsetting
biodiversity and net game schemes that
it won't necessarily be in the location
of the ward where the development is it
it could very easily be somewhere else
as that example is
sure
[Music]
councillor hudson
um thank you mr chairman whilst i think
the ambitions of this uh admirable i
have um one issue of concern
around
the reference to coasts and estuaries
um and how this impacts on coastal
erosion and any remedial works that are
needed
um i don't
i'm concerned that if we
sign up to this about
um respecting and protecting
uh our wildlife on our shores and our
shorelines
uh in one hand and then having to take
action
in another that this this authority is
going to be
torn between
two um
commitments
um and that is the only aspect of this
with uh
high tide i think it's referred to
in 2.5
relating to reducing disturbance at high
tide roosts around the tall torridge
estuary
i have concerns about wetlands about
mudflats
etc when we have
serious ingress of water
into
our land
so i i just want some clarification on
um
we know we've had challenges with
natural england
and various other bodies protecting
their specific area of interest when
we've been trying to progress things so
i'd like some clarification on that the
rest of it fine
happy with fine the um i'm happy to
answer that chair and the the
declaration has no
binding targets or set actions in it
it's purely
a vision
aspirations and a commitment to work
with the biosphere
going forward so i think
um what you're describing is is
absolutely valid and
it highlights the um the difficulty the
local authority has in balancing um very
different but very pressing priorities
and i would hope
um that we can work with the biosphere
to try and find an exception acceptable
solution to all parties i think signing
that declaration
is is about um a commitment to having
those having those discussions but i
mean the biosphere are are well aware of
the uh of the concerns and the pressures
and on the local authority we're getting
very well with them so i think that's
probably a discussion for the future
as to how best those those uh those
pressures all of those pressures can be
met together
a very nice phone yes
we do get on with them yeah but i don't
want to set up something as a precedent
which will lead to conflict in
our argument
of course or against that i don't i
don't feel this permits us to anything
um anything binding
um i it would be more about having those
discussions and including the biosphere
um in in that group in those plans
potentially
thank you
i think if that's indulged in the
recommendations then i would be more
than happy to support you
thanks for the locks
and going on council's point
um say in years to come and i'm not
saying it will happen no one knows
supposing there was an application for
an offshore wind farm in yesteryear
would that be effective
well you know else you know
offshore
it would be a national infrastructure
project so it would be something that
the government would actually decide so
i'm not quite sure what our input would
be
into that process we would be just a
consultant and as with the biosphere and
so we would all have the opportunity to
feed into an application
of that nature but ultimately
besides that so actually signing on to
this declaration
um i'm not sure that that would have any
impact on the decision-making
[Music]
as well
[Music]
it's about raising awareness with
members and staff and businesses about
um the nature recovery plan and it will
be an invite to make their own pledge um
and get involved in those aspirations
[Music]
um i feel that it's rather woolly
without much teeth
quite honestly it looks all very good oh
really you've signed this but actually
what does it mean there isn't anything
that is binding
it also impacts on our agricultural
economy or could do
potentially
and also
janet you mentioned
educating all of us
the people
[Music]
you know you're attacking
essentially this document sort of
could be seen as a bit of an attack on
the agricultural sector
but what about these companies that go
around and basically wipe out and put
down these fake grass maps in people's
gardens
what's that
you know how can we educate the public
it says specifically in this document we
need to be less tidy and less immaculate
be you know
all seeds everywhere and things um but
then you've got a dessert environment
that actually it's really
it's not embracing it even in the
smallest possible space you know people
don't want the maintenance they don't
want the reality is that most residents
want
to not have to maintain anything
you know and the other the flip side is
that the other residents want everyone's
hiding and you know surely we should all
we should be educating
the whole of the public and actually
many farmers don't actually need
educators but in that respect it's quite
condescending
that people who
live around nature all the time
are being told
what to do
um to basically boost it
and yet
you know
in terms of planning
we're not protecting them we're just
offsetting them so it's all right that
we're headed
we'll build here but you can go there
and you'll be nice and happy it doesn't
work like that it's just
it looks very good
if i could just come back on that chair
um i would read the agricultural sector
for this dish but to be absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
it's about sustainable farming it's not
stopping farming it's farming in a
different way
and supporting them and changing into
um
future ways of working which may be
imposed at a later date anyway so um
it's it's not binding um but it's about
the aspirations of all different areas
that we can be involved with and and
that everyone can be involved with so
this is just the starting point in terms
apparently it's very very popular just
don't forget about that
no offense to everyone
[Music]
sure
right chancellor of that level
thank you chair yeah i agree with
councillor
what are you reading this through to be
honest
i mean two days in the declaration talk
to them seek opportunities for netflix
again in all our policies prestigious
plans and operations and decisions and
then three
ensure the principles of building with
nature incorporating new housing
developments that already happens we
already have to address that in the
national planning policy
various councils when you want to listen
to something
what a waste of time things that we've
been taught by the community we were
talking about earlier housing issues and
that and then you can't
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes
there's no actual compulsion
armors aren't being told to do this that
and the other
but the value of this to me is a bit
like you know complaining of climate
emergency it gives a signal
uh together with
um i think a large number of other
groupings organizations etc in the
community
but we are serious about
dealing with
a massive decline in wildlife and uh
we've got to do something about it i
have the biodiversity
of biosphere
i have an action plan practical measures
to deal with the client worldwide and
they're not waffling
on an everyday basis they're
implementing their fans and they're
asking
for full support and declarations from
us and other authorities
and
i think you know this will give the
impetus to this council in all its
actions particularly
which is apparently being carried out
and i can think of another example in
the s3 land review which is apparently
looked at in terms of
um estuary birds for example
this this gives impetus and it signals
our grave commitment to this wholeness
you have to realize what's happening go
outside and see you know hardly any
insects flying around
a whole massive decline not just in the
uk
[Music]
left a yes
in
the last couple of days and then
45 dropping butterflies i have to say
i've never seen so much fun
this year
particularly
um
[Music]
every time we go tournaments
[Music]
attitude that's the farmers who know
best but you know i do remember in her
walk she does have a sewage lake which
is called
local farming
[Music]
the other thing is this idea about our
planning plan somehow
going for an increase in biodiversity uh
council of laws returned to the estate
of a new room which we talked about that
came up before us as planned last week
and i was
slightly disconcerted to hear backwards
to say whether this site is there's no
ecological values a couple of overgrown
ponds
and then they're going to chop some
trees down and they're going to re-plant
something we all know what they'll be
tiny whips that you know probably won't
grow to maturity and i think we do need
to be slightly more proactive in
safeguarding some of these
uh existing
elements of our landscape wrong we're
saying oh we'll get some biodiversity
gains somewhere else i go back to what i
was talking about
treating my awards and helped happiness
but i will say that i think
we do need to look at it very good
[Music]
[Music]
during the
we don't have the slurry lake anymore
however
we do have a
selection of small farmers who actually
have embraced the old scheme
and
whilst it is
um admirable and they do pay you
you know
the reality is that
small farmers struggle
and actually they commit to it and
they
actually love what they do and they want
to embrace the wildlife and that is the
element of
condescension i was
referring to really it's the people who
are passionate about
genuinely what they do working with
nature
um when i was on the couch back in the
1990s the huge subject here was cold
grassland because apparently you have
more calm grassland women's forage than
anywhere else in the country i'm not
having mentioned at all
i trust that it's still there and hasn't
been violated
i'm not going to disagree about your
garden full of butterflies
do have to tell you more people
out of west will go along the cliffs and
along the barracks
and it's not my
memory
um
yeah i mean i represent a very rural
community
i've been
and i would guarantee that every farmer
within my rural area know that their
responsibilities and most of them are
working hard towards by over the fight
everywhere in india and various things
that we need to go back and say i must
encourage you to carry out this they
won't take pride into that
thank you i'm going to put it to the
vote
those in favor please share
one two three four
five
those against
one two
three
i've personally kept out of this debate
i felt it write a problem
as a chair
but this is in my opinion
telling farmers what to do at a terrible
time
because elms is now being brought in we
don't yet know the details of it
to be told that our biodiversity are
right up on
they're not because none of us know the
actual details
you've got a pretty good idea what it's
going to be and it's for profits for
gone
by going into the scheme it's not profit
he gained money
and
whether we like it or not i think the
best thing we've had guardians today
i would ask if you go back and look at
us
thursday's western morning news
and the article by anton toker dartmoor
farmer
neil tell you what he thought of it
he's near the truth
uh we move on
sorry about that i tried to stay
unbiased to cheer to me
thank you chair you would have normally
have the uh operational services manager
and sentence apologies for this evening
so you've got a substitute
members will remember that back in 2016
we were approached by the freshman
society to bring the ss fresh spring to
biddeford at that time there was some
concern because we had no knowledge of
the society or of the boat
that it was uh potentially another wreck
that we would have to deal with in the
harbor of benefit and so it's requested
that they provide us with a bond to
indemnify us uh or provide us with some
money we needed to see
obviously in the intervening years the
ss fresh spring has
seen significant improvement it's become
quite a popular
tourist attraction the society has
proved credible and able
and they've been able to access funding
for its continuum improvement so they
have sought
asking your consent for for us to return
3000 pounds that was paid to us in by
means of bond
to uh for us to keep in case the
freshman phone became a wreck
so that leads me to the recommendations
that have been made by harvard board and
obviously i'm the chair of cardboard as
the chair of cnr who can tell me if i'm
wrong here
uh the recommendation is that we've
returned the three thousand pound bonds
to the freshman societies that can use
it for the continuing good work but the
annual conditions surveys are done to
the votes are presented to harvard
forward and second that
you reserve the right's potential to
reinstate the bond concerns arise
clearly you know i'm going to propose it
from
christie executive
secondly anyone wishing to speak cantona
i just want to make sure the insurance
is still in place the room is still
there if anything happens to the vessel
sorry i'm not reliable for the
boss
and the original wheeler presumably
still enforce
yes i mean the 3000 page was essentially
the insurance policy because
you were holding it
so if everything went wrong you had some
funds
to assist with the cost but they have a
boring agreement there's a there's an
agreement there
it's just simply the finances that
change the they we would be returning
the funds to them there is obviously a
risk then
that if it went wrong uh we would have
to find some funds to supposedly but
we're quite comfortable with that
thanks stacey
there's a separate license agreement
which states that they must have
insurance so that's separate and
responding
yeah that's what i thought was through
the chair of page 27
to insure the patient insurers paying
out business united kingdom and that's
to cover all the record removal expenses
without any reliability
right so three thousand pounds we don't
have a way to clear a wreck
um so that as long as that's still in
place
just just for a reference chair the last
wreck was the
remember now it costs nine thousand
dollars
can i provide one question appendix one
the fresh green trust document second
paragraph
is that although they got the funds set
aside for nine thousand pounds tdz never
asked for the second and third payment
so i just wonder what that was
uh i can't answer that with any
certainty uh chair i think it's probably
a combination do you think one the
agreement was set out by a previous
member
who sees it through and it was a change
of stuff so probably it's a little bit
of we forgot to ask for the second one
the second i i think we became quite
confident that they were a credible
organization there actually wasn't need
[Music]
i think that was because we've had the
reps but with all of the mooring
facilities we have a generally have just
a license which stipulates they must
have insurance they must do because of
that reason
and this was the first time these
members were concerned that we actually
lost repayment up front in case but um
so no we're absolutely fine in that
respect the other
agreements cover us
[Music]
right item 11
leisure contractor pricing proposals
i've got to ask the question of
declaration of interest bearing online
some of us are on the board that will be
enforcing this what's the story
this is the declaration of interest
chair and tightly separate
to the board
[Music]
okay thank you
thank you so so periodically uh our
contractors review their pricing on
their tractor systems
and they are as per the terms of the
contract uh able to propose to you quite
increases or decreases for you to ratify
they've gone through that process uh
they have proposed the schedule of
increases that set out the report and
it's for you to consider those and to
decide whether you are able to endorse
the model
yeah
thank you right uh oh i'll start with
councillor knowledge
no i can't agree with them at all in the
current climate
i won't go into elaborating what i feel
about systems i'm certainly not
intending to support something
which is to the detriment or do
um
[Music]
that's the simple wording of it
anyone else wishing to speak
take a vote on it please those in favor
of that
one two three four uh
making it unanimous
[Music]
anyway
[Music]
clear the meeting closed up oh we've
done it here for 30 minutes
[Music]